[Musique]
1917 einstein y compris que ces
équations de la relativité générale
prédisaient une fin des temps ne pouvait
pas l'accepter il s'empressa alors de
réexaminer sa théorie et la modifiant
cette modification fluent ses propres
termes
la plus grosse bêtise de sa vie on a
déjà parlé de ça dans un vieil épisode
sur la relativité le tld rc qu'en 1915
albert einstein avait bouleversé la
physique en introduisant une toute
nouvelle conception de l'espace du temps
et de la gravité qu'on appelle désormais
la relativité générale cette relativité
générale détrôna les vieilles lois de la
mécanique et de la gravité de newton
sauf que en 1917 un autre chercheur
alexander friedman se rendit compte que
les équations de la relativité générale
pouvait s'appliquer à l'espace temps de
l'univers tout entier mais surtout il
démontra que ces équations prédisaient
une fin des temps pour l'univers
l'univers einstein ne pouvait pas être
stable et sa einstein ne l'acceptent pas
ils sont près ça de modifier ces
équations pour rendre son univers stable
en introduisant notamment une constante
cosmologique plus tard les prédictions
de friedman furent confirmés
expérimentalement quand on découvrit que
l'univers était en expansion
notre cher albert einstein doute alors
reconnaître son erreur il l'appela même
la plus grosse bêtise de sa vie on sait
pas vraiment pour quelle raison une
stein tenait absolument à un univers
stationnaire il ya à priori ça tient
plus de la conviction qu autre chose
qu'une espèce d'intuition viscérale qui
l'avait on peut bien imaginer que
l'univers à terme s'effondrera sur
lui-même sauf quel style veut que son
univers restent stationnaires et donc
pour pâques tout s'effondre il va
imaginer une force une espèce
d'antigravité une force répulsive dans
l'univers bien qu'elle ne repose sur
absolument rien d'autre que ne faire
marcher son modèle et qui va appeler
constante cosmologique et avant de
publier son modèle cosmologique il va
écrire à pau les rênes fait ce qui est
par la mine et physicien autrichien
j'ai encore commis quelque chose à
propos de la terre
la gravitation qui d'une certaine
manière mais exposé au danger de me
faire interner dans un asile de fous il
le sait que son idée repose sur rien du
tout alors je vais pas aller jusqu'à
dire qu'elle stagne a fait un saut de la
foi qu'il faut pas déconner non plus
mais merde le 'guide' est tellement
convaincu que sa représentation univers
est correct qui va artificiellement
rajouter un truc juste pour que ça
marche mais pourquoi albert pourquoi bon
clairement c'est très difficile de
savoir ce qui se passait vraiment dans
la tête de notre cher albert notamment
parce qu'il s'est passé sans doute des
choses
affreusement complexe en tout cas pour
mon petit cerveau de physiciens amateurs
en fait je ne suis même pas sûr que lui
savait exactement ce qu'il se passait
dans sa tête
souvent en recherche on a des idées et
c'est seulement après coup qu'on essaie
de justifier le pourquoi du comment de
ces idées retracer le cheminement de la
pensée est souvent un exercice difficile
donc je vais un peu spéculer pour
aujourd'hui
en particulier je vais spéculer sur une
hypothèse qui me paraît tout de même
assez probable je vais parier sur le
fait qu albert a subi ce que julia
ghallef appelle le sophisme des
croyances orpheline
vous voyez de quoi je veux parler pour
comprendre tout ça on va faire un bond
en arrière et essayer de comprendre
comment une structure nos croyances
typiquement on va construire ses
croyances à partir de fondement et nos
croyances seront ensuite des
conséquences de ses fondements
typiquement je crois à et a impliqué du
coup je crois aussi b en fait notre
façon de penser aux semble même
davantage à tout un réseau de variables
interconnectés par exemple par des liens
de cause à effet pour être plus concret
on peut prendre l'exemple donné par la
statistique expliqué à mon chat dans ce
super épisode pour expliquer la
différence entre corrélation et
causalité dans ce cas albert pas celui
qui fait des bêtises mais le chat albert
a expliqué la corrélation entre chocolat
et prix nobel en invoquant une cause
commune à savoir la richesse albert a
ainsi décrit un modèle selon lequel la
richesse cause la consommation du
chocolat et la richesse cause les prix
nobel alors petite précision bien sûr
ces liens de causalité ne sont
absolument pas des implications directes
il ne suffit pas d'être riche pour
consommer du chocolat est assez
clairement il ne suffit pas de faux
riches pour gagner le prix nobel non ces
liens de causalité sont des causalités
probabiliste en fait que ce qu'il
faudrait dire c'est plutôt que le fait
d'être riche cause une
augmentation de la probabilité de
consommer du chocolat la richesse cause
aussi une augmentation de la probabilité
de gagner le prix nobel
la causalité ici correspond donc à une
augmentation du risque est absolument
pas à une implication logique en
pratique dans nos têtes on a des liens
kozo probabiliste entre toutes sortes de
variables par exemple on a tous des
modèles internes qui me disent des
choses comme le fait que l'appétit
augmente aussi la probabilité de
consommation de chocolat et que cette
consommation de chocolat augmente aussi
la probabilité de cholestérol mais aussi
la probabilité de joie ce que fait aussi
d'ailleurs le fait de gagner un prix
nobel
bien sûr à l'écran je n'ai mis qu'une
poignée de concept mais il faut bien
imaginer que en pratique même si l'on en
est souvent inconscient on dispose d'un
énorme ensemble de concepts et de
nombreux liens de causalité entre ces
concepts et l'on fait souvent appel à
une partie de cet énorme réseau de
concept pour raisonner en pratique et en
particulier émettre des préjugés plus ou
moins parisien un tel réseau de concepts
liés par des liens de cause à effet est
appelé un réseau bayésiens aujourd'hui
les réseaux parisiens sont souvent vus
comme fondement de la pensée causale en
tout cas en statistiques et en machine
learning
d'ailleurs le père des réseaux bayésiens
un certain juillet apple a gagné la plus
haute distinction de l'informatique
le prix du riz pour son étude des
réseaux parisiens
cependant pour tout vous dire les
réseaux bayésiens ne sont en fait pas
fondamentalement bayésiens c'est une
appellation qui est un peu inadéquate
il est en fait largement possible
d'étudier les réseaux bayésiens samba et
sionisme tout comme il est entièrement
possible dû faire du buzz à nice mme
sans réseau bayésiens en fait pour
clarifier la nature des réseaux
bayésiens il serait plus adéquat de les
appeler des graphes de causalité sport
ce n'est pas si gênant de les appeler
réseau malien notamment parce que bon en
pratique ou les analyses bien souvent
avec des raisonnements bayésiens j'ai
même envie de dire qu'un réseau bastien
est probablement analysés par des
raisonnements parisien même si un réseau
bayen ne s'appuie probablement pas sur
un réseau parisien
quelque chose prenons un exemple
imaginer un individu si vous êtes
bayésiens vous devriez alors avoir un
préjugé sur sa richesse et son appétit
ce préjugé doit alors impliqué des
consommation de chocolat probable est
une certaine probabilité sur le fait que
l'individu à un prix nobel
voilà qui implique ensuite diverses
probabilité sur son niveau de
cholestérol et son niveau de joie
imaginons maintenant que vous appreniez
que l'individu est en fait très riche
cette donnée change alors votre préjugés
sur la richesse de l'individu cette
modification modifie alors en cascade
les probabilités sur les autres
variables de notre graphe de causalité
en tout cas c'est ainsi que devrait
résonner un bézian mais il y a peu
compliqué imaginons que vous découvriez
que l'individu est en fait joyeux bien
si on applique la formule deux pays''
cette information nouvelle devrait
impliquer des croyances différentes
avoir sur les variables qui causent la
joie en effet sachant que l'individu et
joyeux il semble alors plus probable
qu'ils consomment du chocolat et qu'il
ait gagné un prix nobel
alors je précise ses probabilités n'ont
fait qu'augmenter
mais le préjugé peut être si bas que
même un peu austère youri sachant que
l'individu et joyeux ces probabilités
peuvent rester très faible à l'individu
qui est joyeux a plus de chances d'avoir
gagné un prix nobel que si on ne savait
pas si les joyeux cependant même sachant
qu'il est joyeux il reste encore
improbable qu'il ait effectivement gagné
un prix nobel
un individu qui a gagné un prix nobel
est très probablement joyeux mais un
individu joyeux un très probablement pas
gagné le prix nobel
quelque chose est bien sûr notre
inférences bayésienne vers le haut ne
s'arrête pas là vu que l'individu
consomment plus probablement du chocolat
et a plus de chances d'avoir gagné un
prix nobel
le fait qu'on sache qu'ils soient plus
joyeux implique aussi que l'individu et
plus probablement riche et qu'il a plus
probablement un certain appétit la
propagation en honte tout en haut de la
chaîne de causalité
ok jusque là c'est peut-être un peu
complexe mais ça reste encore assez
intuitif mais il y à des raisonnements
palaisien troublant à faire sur les
réseaux parisiens
supposons maintenant qu en plus
d'observer le fait que l'individu est
joyeux est riche on découvre que
l'individu a gagné un prix nobel
cette fois il s'agit de voir les
conséquences d'une modification de notre
croyance sur la variable nobel mais en
gardant les cases joie et riche fixe est
ce que vous seriez capable de deviner
quelles seraient les conséquences de ce
modification de croyance et bien il se
trouve que dans ce cas la probabilité
qu'ils mangent du chocolat diminue et
oui de manière à super étrange une
modification d'une variable conditionné
à des variables inchangés dans d'autres
lignes peut impliquer une modification
des croyances sur la même ligne il ya en
fait toute une mécanique assez complexe
de la propagation des modifications de
croyance dans le réseau bayésiens
intuitivement ce qui se passe c'est que
pour expliquer la joie d'un individu il
faut un minimum de chocolat ou de prix
nobel
mais du coup sachant que l'individu à le
prix nobel n'a plus vraiment besoin de
supposer qu'ils consomment du chocolat
est en fait il devient moins probable
qu'ils consomment chocolat la version
plus rigoureuse de ce phénomène est
appelé le paradoxe de berck sonne élevé
vous laisse y réfléchir mais il explique
pourquoi les joueurs de football
professionnels sont plutôt petit et
technique où grands et maladroit ou
pourquoi les chanteurs professionnels on
voit incroyable un physique potable ou
une voix passable et un physique hyper
séduisant
quoi qu'il en soit j'espère vous avoir
ray les réseaux bayésiens de nos
cerveaux c'est en fait vraiment pas
facile et encore là on a étudié que six
concepts mais en pratique dans nos
cerveaux il ya des milliers de concept
entremêlés clairement il nous est
impossible de déterminer comment une
information qui change la valeur d'une
variable modifie les valeurs probable
des autres variables
ce calcul des propagations des croyances
benziane est juste horrible a effectué
en pratique et nos cerveaux de primates
ont une attention très limitée est en
fait loin de moi l'idée de vous motiver
à effectuer constamment des quelques bas
et bien sûr les réseaux bayésiens dans
le cerveau ce serait complètement
épuisant non vous ne pourrez pas faire
les calculs bayésiens en tout cas pas
les calculs exacts et ce n'est pas grave
certains de mes meilleurs amis n'arrive
pas à faire des calculs bayésiens mais
je les aime quand même et il vaut mieux
parce que clairement je n'arrive
absolument pas à gérer moi-même un iota
de la complexité des calculs parisien
qu'il faudrait faire pour gérer
adéquatement mon propre réseau baptisé
en interne ne pas appliquer la forme de
baise c'est pas grave ça nous arrive
tout le temps cependant ce qui est
crucial c'est de bien se rendre compte
que nous ne faisons pas ce calcul va et
vient ce qui va inéluctablement nous
conduire à des incohérences dans notre
réseau bézian interne comme le dit julia
ghallef il faut connaître les limites de
nos cerveaux pour déterminer les limites
de notre pensée est pour mieux
comprendre comment l'utiliser au mieux
et en particulier il est crucial de
noter que nos cerveaux ne calcule pas
des réseaux bayésiens cohérent
typiquement idéalement quand dans nos
cerveaux on a une flèche à un pic b
comme disons prix nobel implique page
wikipédia alors une remise en cause de à
devrait impliquer une remise en cause de
b autrement dit ici on croyait que jean
lui à un prix nobel
alors vous devinerez qu'il a une page
wikipédia supposons tout à coup qu'on
découvre qui n'en fait pas de prix nobel
idéalement il faudrait alors douté du
fait qu'il a une page wikipédia
sauf que comme l'expliquent julia khelef
nos cerveaux ne sont pas des réseaux
vraiment bayésiens y compris dans le cas
le plus simple de propagation de
croyances païennes dans un réseau baeza
nos cerveaux échouent souvent à propager
les conséquences d'une nouvelle
information
mais alors il est très possible qu'on
garde à l'esprit une conséquence b d'une
cause
à
aussi que même une fois qu'on a rejeté
la cause ah on persiste à croire en la
conséquence b la croyance b serait alors
ce que julia ghallef appelle une
croyance orpheline
c'est à dire une croyance dont la
croyance mère est morte
le sophisme des croyances orpheline
c'est alors de persister à protéger des
croyances y compris après avoir accepté
la mort des croyances parente
or selon la formule de base quand les
parents meurent il faut immédiatement
tué les enfants
je pense que je viens de dire une phrase
qui ne faut absolument pas sortir de son
contexte
juste pour clarifier je parle de
croyance parentes et de croyances fille
voilà je pense que c'est un petit peu
mieux comme ça prenons un exemple qui va
être un petit peu controversé donc je
m'excuse si ça vous choque mais
typiquement certains préceptes religieux
semblent impliquer une condamnation de
la masturbation
dès lors un individu qui adhéreraient à
ses préceptes peut vouloir condamner la
masturbation son raisonnement de cause à
effet serait alors justifié il serait
conforme au bail à nice mme même si sur
une hypothèse est potentiellement
discutable imaginons maintenant que plus
tard cet individu rejette désormais ses
préceptes religieux
l'individu ne serait alors plus
justifiée a condamné la masturbation
malheureusement il est alors probable
que parce que cet individu des papes
bayésiens ils n'arrivent pas à analyser
suffisamment sa pensée pour comprendre
que la condamnation de la masturbation
n'est plus justifiée par son réseau
bayésiens cette croyance sur la
masturbation serait alors devenue une
croyance orpheline eh bien il me semble
que tout ça c'est peut-être ce qui est
arrivé à notre cher albert avant
l'avènement de la relativité générale
beaucoup de génie avait étudié la
question de la stabilité de l'univers
avec le bémol qu'avant albert univers
était essentiellement restreint au
système solaire mais justement la place
semblaient avoir montré que les lois de
newton impliquer la stabilité du système
solaire est ce un siècle avant albert
il était alors communément admis que à
cause de lois de newton
l'univers est nécessairement stable mais
ce fut peut-être tellement admis que la
stabilité de l'univers et possiblement
de
un lieu dangereusement commun de la
communauté scientifique en général et
d'albert en particulier il s'était mis à
y croire mais il semblait avoir oublié
pourquoi il y croyait mais alors
lorsqu'albert à destituer les lois de
newton n'a pas remarqué qu'il tuait là
les parents de sa croyance ne s'était
pas rendu compte qu'il avait rendu sa
croyance orphelines et qu'il était donc
temps de la tuer
et du coup au lieu de tuer sa créance
orpheline il s'est agrippé il en a fait
un point de crispation
même s'il ne disposait plus d'aucune
bonne raison pour la justifier
c'est pourquoi il me semble probable que
le sophisme derrière la plus grosse
bêtise d'einstein
ce fut une croyante orpheline justifiée
par une mécanique newtonienne qu'albert
venait pourtant de tuer lui-même
ça fait un effet
surtout ça même le publions des
scientifiques de l'histoire était
vulnérable au sophisme des croyances
orpheline
mais alors quid de nous quelles sont nos
croyances orpheline
en particulier je vous invite à
réfléchir à vos croyances orpheline est
allé listé en commentaire une petite et
norman ans avant de revenir aux
commentaires de la vidéo précédente dans
quelques jours va sortir un nouveau
livre le livre le fabuleux chante hier
entre intelligence artificielle
robustement bénéfique coécrit avec mehdi
el mhamdi est publié aux éditions au dp
science et jeudi geoffrey une vidéo qui
peut entrer un peu plus ce livre et on
fera également une conférence live avec
médias même dit à le pfl donc si vous
êtes autour de lausanne
venez c'est complètement gratuit et ce
sera dans la salle e bc 0,1 à le pfl est
a priori on essaiera de faire ça
également en youtube live donc si vous
voulez voir le lancement de ce tout
nouveau livret et bien rendez vous jeudi
prochain la 1ère fois que j'avais
demandé à quoi ressemble un musulman
d'ailleurs je vous invite à aller voir
cette vidéo si vous voulez en savoir
plus y ai fait la remarque que un
terrain de vannes pourrait permettre de
mieux clarifier tout ça en fait va
falloir faire un peu mieux qu un
diagramme de venn parce que le diagramme
de venn prennent pas les probabilités a
priori mais si on fait des diagramme de
venn ou le l'air d'une surface
correspond à la probabilité de
l'événement eh bien on obtient un
diagramme de venn probabiliste en un
sens et justement on peut faire un
diagramme de venn pour la relation entre
par exemple les musulmans et les arabes
ça ressemble à quelque chose comme ça en
fait on voit que la plupart des humains
sur terre sont
a priori des asiatiques et même si on
prend deux buts la partie musulman comme
la partie musulman de partie asiatique
correspond à un tiers et à partie un
musulman de partis arabes correspond à
90% et bien mais ma posture yens obtient
des parties coloré ici qui sont beaucoup
plus du côté asiatique que du côté arabe
et c'est pour ça que la plupart des
musulmans sous amphètes asiatiques ou
dit autrement un musulman et plus
probablement asiatique qu'arabes et ga
cabab lui fait la remarque que on a
considéré à la fois un humain tirer au
hasard sur terre mais on peut considérer
à un humain tiré par exemple en france
maintenant on découvre qui est musulman
à quoi ressemble-t-il de probablement et
bien en effet il se trouve que là cette
fois on a une probabilité conditionnelle
mais cette fois également conditionné
localement géographiquement et à ce
moment là
sachant qu'une personne est musulmane et
sachant qu'elle se trouve en france
en fait il est assez probable qu'elle
est soit arabe une fac il y à un
commentaire qui nous vient de la
nouvelle calédonie et tué leurs marques
jaunes nouvelle calédonie ça fait partie
de la france mais qu'en nouvelle
calédonie la plupart des musulmans sont
en fait des indonésiens
parce que c'est une nouvelle qui a donné
beaucoup de proches de l'indonésie
qu'elle ne l'est du moyen-orient et du
maghreb
de façon plus générale il est important
de remarquer que quand on conditionne
par rapport à quelque chose en plus on
obtient des probabilités différentes
comme le dirait le proverbe bayésiens
sans conteste sans contexte c'est la
mauvaise probabilité conteste j'espère
qu'ils avaient aimé cet épisode puisque
ça vous aide
petit à petit avoir plus d'outils pour
faire du bail à nice mme pragmatique
donc un bon conseil issus de ces
épisodes c'est de toujours réfléchir à
pourquoi est ce qu'on croit surtout
trois recherchés à visualiser votre
réseau bézian interne avec lequel on
fait la plupart de nos raisonnements et
a surtout évité ce dangereux risque des
croyances orpheline la prochaine fois on
verra un outil complètement différent
pour permettre de mieux raisonner de
votre bail viennent et c'est un truc
absolument inédit dans l'histoire de
toute information qui existent au monde
jusqu'à public à ma connaissance
donc c'est un truc que je trouve
terriblement excitant et qui a qui
pourrait être largement appliquée dans
moi à finir si possible dans des salles
de classe
c'est vraiment un truc que je trouve
absolument générale ou parlera en fait
des qcm bayésiens si vous avez aimé cet
épisode dont c'est le lac et le
commentaire partagé pensez à vous
abonner pour me sentir un épisode noir
ce type est un pardon et j'espère que je
serai là
la prochaine fois lorsqu'elle bernstein
mis au point la théorie de la relativité
générale qui est je le rappelle une
théorie universelle de la gravitation
il a une idée en tête et qui n'est pas
spécialement réussi à d'ailleurs mais
c'est une idée qu'on se traîne depuis
très très longtemps
l'univers est stationnaire en d'autres
termes l'univers a toujours été là et il
sera toujours là alors éventuellement
dans cet univers bien sûr il ya des
choses qui naissent des choses
himeur des choses qui se déplacent mais
l'univers lui-même est stationnaire wang
a été abolie
[Musique]